freunde wir machen heute etwas ganz ganz
einfaches ist brauchen wir auch nur ein
koffer das andere können wir getrost weg
stellen wir kommen nämlich heute walcott
gerichte und dass wir das alles hat fürs
erste brauchen eine wunderschöne
produktvielfalt wir haben verfalle oder
generell kleine papst apag fleisch
tomatenmark zwiebel knoblauch sahne
rinderbrühe granacher dame ein paar
gewürze und gefrorene apps und die
nächste sache die wir jetzt brauchen ist
ein port also ein top ich denke ganz
viele von euch lieben wie ich auch das
kochen und passen wie ich auch das
saubermachen deshalb sind j gerichte
schon was feines für mich schwingt da
immer so ein bisschen mit ist das
wirklich das meiste was man aus einem
gericht rausholen kann ist mit einem
kopf zu toppen ist mit einem topf zu
kochen nicht einfach faul und wenn man
es mit zwei drei vier fünf töpfen und
pfannen machen würde wäre das ergebnis
besser wir werden uns heute überzeugen
das erste gericht ist von sally die
zutaten habe ich euch ja schon gesagt
wir fangen an und wäre der topf waren
kümmere ich mich schon warum unsere
zwiebel und die zwei knoblauchzehen also
ist auf jeden fall ein gericht kein
wunder dass auf tik tok sportgerichte so
krass laufen die breite masse ist wenn
sie schon kennt natürlich nicht gewählt
dann auch noch alles auf so groß ist
eigentlich mehr beiläufig aufgefallen
dass die ganzen gerichte auch unter zehn
euro weg
das heißt wir wie immer ein wenig
olivenöl und unseren top hinein und
schon mal das hackfleisch
schnell her der induktion wie das erste
der neuen küche diejenigen unter euch
die mir auf instagram folgen hatten
schon die große freude einen ersten
blick auf meine neue küche zu werten
endstufe fans soweit ist kommt auch auf
youtube ein video dazu aber ich freue
mich wirklich unglaublich darauf wir
machen das ganze heute ganz hackfleisch
ist angesagt und
sehr wirklich gespannt denn die nennt
das gericht ja kraft aber sowohl
italiener als auch mexikaner sind
beleidigt aber wir gucken ob wir auch
beleidigt sein werden jetzt
thematisieren wir das ganze 25 jahren
tomatenmark sport chance schön war
wieder dran kommt hinterher mit unseren
knoblauch früher rinderbrühe
das macht das ganze schon wieder mehr zu
takko ein wenig sahne das macht das
ganze schon wieder nur weniger sonntag
werden wir das ganze mal durch und
warten bis es auftaucht so dass ganze
kocht jetzt gehen wir mit gewürzen
reihen chili oregano paprika edelsüß
weißer pfeffer kreuzkümmel und ein
lorbeerblatt sachs wieder mehr
mexikanisch die sächsin die sich
unendlich sind am unternehmen und da das
ganze jetzt aufgekocht ist können wir
auch unsere nudeln hinzu kämen bei einer
dampfross wieder weniger mexikanische
und dann hören wir das ganze einmal
schön durch natürlich auch nicht fehlen
darf ein wenig salz und das schöne ist
jetzt die nudeln kochen in der soße
nehmen deshalb den geschmack auf und
gleichzeitig geben die stärke abfinden
die soße direkt hat schon viel
sinnvolles deckel drauf und wir warten
erstmal so acht minuten hat es sind
nicht mal zehn minuten vergangen wir
haben kaum geschnibbelt einfach nur
sachen zusammen geworfen und wir sind
fast schon fertig ich habe jetzt
gefrorene erbsen die ich auch noch dazu
gebe keine ahnung 34 minuten vor ende
der kochzeit wir haben unter 10 euro und
unter zehn minuten alter das ist schon
leicht gemacht es ist
kurz vor schluss geben wir jetzt auch
über den käse dran der bindet noch
einmal weiter unsere pasta saucen würden
die ein bisschen runter oder merkt schon
die wird so langsam ein bisschen sie mir
ja noch ein bisschen zeit bis
schlussendlich jetzt auch eine
gefühlssache oder muss man einfach
kühlen kann einfach den richtigen moment
warten mehr oder weniger
wollen wir sie raus willst du mal
abschmecken
da kommt wir haben eine spontane testen
ich weiß auch nicht mehr das ist lass
uns mal gemeinsam probiert lag
aber mit sagen so gute quote von der
gemeinde ist noch heiß wir probieren
motto passt
gut ich glaube das ist so eine passiert
erstmal nicht heiß heiß essen ich fühle
ja
muss ein bisschen abkühlen und dann
braucht man sich extra wenig weil ich
zwei weitere töpfe mache dann braucht
man so einen riesigen schüssel und dann
geht so
dabei hatten wir so eine terrasse
also ich muss sagen für mich ist das
würde eigentlich ist es nicht so lecker
aber wenn ich das jetzt vergleichen mit
so einem vollwertigen geilen
durchgedacht ein pastagericht ist auch
sehr stark gewürzt rezepte ich würde dem
ganzen so eine sieben von zehn für den
aufwand zwei besuchen auf jeden fall
eine geile sache aber eine zutat wird
auch im nächsten gericht ein comeback
machen schauen wir mal was es wird
kommen wir zum zweiten landgericht ihr
seht es die erbsen machen wieder ihren
auftritt genauso natürlich auch ein
bisschen öl das gehen wir die fahne
hinein und gehen wir auch direkt unsere
erbsen und das zwiebel unsere zwiebeln
dann würde ich sagen kommen zwiebeln als
nächstes in die pfanne und war tief
gefroren ist wie
ein zweiter lieblingsgerichte ist ja
toll oecd und deshalb habe ich große
erwartungen an das hier das ist von
einem tick tock und zwar von angelo
kursziel vielleicht kennt ihr euch
dieses gericht ist wirklich denkt war
das einfachste was jemals irgendwo auf
der welt gekauft wurde so dürfen wir das
ganze zehn minuten lang durch so dass
die ersten aufgetaut und die zwiebeln
gedacht sind und weil es natürlich viel
zu sagen gibt würde ich sagen wir sehen
uns dann einfach gleich wieder so sieht
das ganze aus wenn es fertig ist dann
können wir uns auch schon einen
stabmixer greifen und die hälfte der
erbsen zu einer schönen zu einem test
topics
dass wir dazu wenn wir diesen zustand
erreicht haben kommen unsere nudeln
drauf und zu den nudeln noch einiges an
wasser
dass sie möglichst interessante aus der
startliste aus dem eigentlichen rezepte
bisschen besser funktionieren aber ich
bin guter dinge hängen wir das ganze mal
durch ich frage mich wie das so schön
fein poliert bekommen hat nicht alles
mal erlaubt da waren kleiner kater
ein bisschen movie magic involviert wie
man das ganze natürlich so wie es
wirklich funktioniert denkbar der hat
das einfach aus der pfanne raus
messbecher getan dort perfekt gemixt und
dann in meinem leben zeit stand auch
hier wieder der gleiche effekt das
schöne ist dass die nun jetzt quasi hier
stärker etwa abheben und ich glaube auch
aus erbsen kommen eine ganz nette soest
zaubern deshalb das cremige wird auf
jeden fall gewährleistet sein wir lassen
das ganze jetzt ein bisschen köcheln
bereit uns gut im blick und dann gucken
wir mal das aus wenn wir merken dass die
pasta al dente ist geben wir unseren
käse obendrauf geriebenen parmesan 45
gramm dann nochmal ein stückchen von
unseren warmen wasser das ist wirklich
unglaublich übrigens wie viel ich jetzt
davon schon drin habe es war locker ein
halber liter
[Musik]
ich glaube die schmeckt trotzdem ich
glaube auch dass er schmeckt platane
seines kleine süße von den erbsen konnte
stimmte auch sehr sehr lecker daher auch
sehr gefährlich gefährlich und die süß
sowie soziales süßen machen wir total
fertig rigatoni erbsen parmesan ein
bisschen zeit das ist alles was in
dieser portion pasta steckt und sie
sieht nicht so schön aus wie im video
das er gesagt aber vielleicht schmeckt
sie ja sehr gut dafür haben auf jeden
fall so was wie eine soße bekommen schon
einmal
[Musik]
ganz eigene art und weil das ist so eins
vor erbsensuppe so aber der nudeln
dazwischen und durch die vielen vielen
erbstg war das auch eine nicht zu
verneinen die süße aber die soeste sieht
schon sämig aus ja ist ja auch nichts
was ich ein zweites mal kochen würde
schrecklich schlecht aber es ist einfach
nicht erstrebenswert
gerade bei 710 jetzt bin ich sehr
gespannt nächsten halt konzern probiert
es mal mit dem einfach nur eine gabel
weil es ist halt so eigenartig so aber
ich glaube das könnte leuten auch
richtig gut schmecken
ja aber ich meine so wie geil verlust
von 10 das willst du dir kochen eine
sache die acht konzerten das würdest du
es sagen okay das komme ich nochmal das
wirst du dir kommen schon da hat darauf
so zum gedünstetes pangasius ja ich uns
ernst ist so eine richtig geile leichte
passt aber geschmäcker sind verschieden
aber würdest du dir das kochen genau so
wie du es jetzt gemacht hast nicht aber
generell der erbsen pastor finde ich
habe da seine berechtigung ich bleibe
bei meiner bewertung bei der letzten
sache habe ich selbst ein paar sachen
zusammen gebastelt und mein eigenes wort
gericht zu kreieren haben bestimmt schon
viele leute vor mir so gemacht aber wir
machen vonn ports baguette ebay eur bzw
cappellini jojo ich habe so ein bisschen
von dem perfekten ali ollie ich euch
gezeigt habe und der lemon pasta die wir
letztens im 20 euro video hatten
zusammen geworfen um mit dass hier über
dich ist sollte eigentlich ziemlich gut
funktionieren und so wie ich es verstehe
haben wir auch keine wirklichen
nachteile dadurch dass das man papier
ist ich hoffe das geht so auf wie es mir
dennoch erstmal ordentlich und lieben öl
in die pfanne ein hauptbestandteil des
konzept habe hier ein paar schwimmens
welche ich komplett aufgetaut habe
und diesmal ich weiß dass er von ob
wollen wir sie wirklich nur kurz
anbraten weil die nudeln kochen ja auch
noch wenn ihr mit in der pfanne sind
wenn das erledigt ist gehen wir auch
schon normalerweise macht einen euro den
körper etwas später dran die machen das
jetzt schon beim abgleich kopf das ganze
ja nur noch wir wollen das ja auch ein
bisschen trösten abgekommen und mit
nicht verbrennt oder frauen sind aber so
ein bisschen darf es schon mal so
station ich glaube irgendwie dass das
gut funktioniert wird das denkst du
darauf so ich glaube das reicht dann
ausschauen und mit dem anbraten jetzt
geben wir unsere musik ihr das mal so
komisch sprudeln hinein und dann kommt
auch schon ein wenig warmes wasser dazu
ein wenig mehr vielleicht auch nach dem
zeitpunkt heißt es jetzt wir müssen
gucken ab wann sie so ein bisschen
biegsamen sind
wasser schon fast verschwunden
es war wirklich viel wasser was
geschützt werden und ist komplett
verschwunden weil das scheint möglichst
gut zu funktionieren also jetzt gerade
ist es noch freundlich flüssig aber es
geht in eine gute richtung wir werden es
sehen nachdem ich jetzt ungefähr einen
halben liter wasser und ein bisschen
zeit zu dem jungen gegeben habe wie das
ganze so aus ist es nicht ganz so
dickflüssig wie ich es gerne hätte aber
die nudel haben jetzt auf jeden fall
ihren gewünschten gar heitz grad
erreicht bin gespannt wie gut das
funktioniert hat gibt nochmal die
petersilie dazu sie sieht nicht scheiße
aus aber ich glaube es schlägt auf jeden
fall nicht die normale richtige
zubereitungsart von heute irgendwo muss
ja das ganze wasser und öl auch hingehen
soll das ist ja in den nudeln an den
hmm schwarzer pfeffer ein wenig barbian
und fertig sind ein bisschen komisch
aussehen cappellini ali ollie klingt gut
wir sehen auf jeden fall nicht so wie
ich es bei den auto union zu letzten mal
gemacht aber liebe so eine schicht die
schon fast so ein bisschen aussieht wie
so eine mario die sich so um die mobilen
gelegt hat aber vielleicht ist
geschmacklich trotzdem noch viel drin
aber schauen wir dann hier siehst oder
ist nicht so diese krasse source das
liegt halt wahrscheinlich auch einfach
an der kultur also an der kochzeit
probleme
sehr positiv überrascht von den garnelen
die pasta berlin sind auch so dass beide
zu essen die machen so spart man mit
jedem bissen zerschneiden deine zähne so
100 kleine kügelchen die schärfe und
natürlich ist es perfekt findet steht
einer standard aldi olio um nichts nach
da fehlt jetzt nicht so aber diese geile
mutierte unfassbar cremige mio er ist
auf jeden fall nochmal eine stufe höher
weil wenn man so unten an den
kellerboden geht schwäbischen holt
das ist schon richtig richtig frau oder
es ist schon und trotzdem auch cremig
das hat mich so dieses so sicher aber es
ist trotzdem sehr krebs dann auch
trotzdem eine geschmacksintensität ja
wie ordnen wir das ganze jetzt ein tag
ist das war die beste von den drei passt
also nicht weil ich mir selbst überlegt
habe sondern weil sie mit wenig aufwand
am nächsten dann etwas bekanntes
rankommt 419 man spart sich den aufwand
man hat trotzdem ein geiles ergebnis und
es ist nicht 100 prozent von dem
möglichen aber man hat auch nur eine
pfanne zum saubermachen dementsprechend
don't believe the hype glaubte ich alles
was sie auf social media sind generell
so bei tik tok und so denke ich mir auch
manchmal so wollen das nächste wäre alle
gerichte kreieren und tun als sei es das
krasse der welt aber manchmal erfordern
leckere gerichte halt auch ein bisschen
arbeit in der küche verfolgt dass sie
nur drei verfahren sauber machen muss
das mache ich jetzt wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder bis dahin und
schauen